télévision ordinateur smartphone
tablette depuis quelques années la
déferland des écrans à métamorphoser
notre quotidien et si ce phénomène
n'était-il pas devenu un véritable enjeu
de santé publique chez les plus jeunes
c'est la question posée par ce
documentaire cette enquête réalisée par
le journaliste raphaëel Itier que nous
recevons maintenant dans cette émission
débadog bienvenue Raphael Itier vous
avez choisi de devenir journaliste après
avoir obtenu un doctorat en éthique
moléculaire et vous êtes spécialisé
ensuite dans l'écriture et la
réalisation de documentaires
scientifiques vous êtes aussi un
intervenant régulier un chroniqueur sur
notre chaîne dans notre émission dédiée
à l'écologie maman j'ai arrêté l'avion
et l'on vous doit donc ce génération
écran génération malade avec un point
d'interrogation hein bien sûr que nous
venons de voir à l'instant et dont nous
allons bien sûr reparler ensemble sur ce
plateau nous allons le faire avec vous
Sabine Duflot bienvenue vous êtes
psychologue clinicienne et thérapeute
familiale et vous êtes par ailleurs
membre du collectif surexosition écran
vous êtes également l'auteur de ce livre
il ne décroche pas des écrans la méthode
des quatre pas pour protéger le cerveau
des enfants c'est un livre publié aux
éditions marabou et puis enfin Serge
Tisseron est avec nous bienvenue con on
vous a vu hein dans ce film et pour
cause he vous avez été le conseiller
Scien ifique de ce documentaire vous
êtes psychiatre et docteur en
psychologie et vous êtes l'auteur entre
autres entre autres de 3 6 91
apprivoiser les écrans et grandir
publiés aux éditions
RS Raphaël Itier vous avez pris des
précautions au tout début de ce film et
elles sont nécessaires hein peut-être
pour planter le décor après avoir vu
votre votre
enquête vous précisez que l'exposition
aux écrans date d'environ aujourd'hui
une quinzaine d'années chez les enfants
et les adolescents et qu'il faut en
moyenne 20 ans de recherche scientifique
pour démontrer lesffet d'un nouveau
facteur sur le corps humain autrement
dit à ce stade aucune étude scientifique
ne peut vraiment faire foi dans le sujet
qui nous concerne aujourd'hui alors si
il existe des des études scientifiques
il en existe même de plus en plus voire
énormément qui sont pas toutes
convergantes euh c'est très compliqué de
de de démontrer l'effet nocif de quelque
chose il faut du recul c'est ce que dit
et là da Bavelier on manque toujours de
de de recul ce que dit Dafné Bavelier
qui est qui est donc une une
scientifique qui travaille en qui
travaille en Suisse c'est qu'il faut en
moyenne 20 ans pour rétablir la nocivité
de de quelque chose et donc là les
choses se sont passées de telle façon
que les gamins se retrouvent avec des
avec des des écrans entre les mains sans
qu'on ait ce ce recul donc du coup la
science peut pas être euh affirmative
pour l'instant le seul moyen que l'on a
d'avancer c'est de regarder toutes ces
études qui ne sont pas toujours
convergente et il y en a une qui est
sortie il y a très peu ce qu'on appelle
une une une étude parapluie qui VI qui
vient réunir un peu toutes toutes les
toutes les études pe sorti après votre
documentaire qui est sorti oui le mois
dernier le mois dernier donc du coup la
la dernière je dirais euh le le le le
actualisation dans dans le domaine est
lié à cette à cette cette étude euh qui
ne conclut pas des liens très très forts
très importants mais c'est aussi une
étude qu'on peut critiquer parce que on
peut passer à côté de certaines choses
du fait du côté parapluis très général
et ça ça ça ça estompe peut-être des
effets mais si on veut se se se
positionner du point de vue strictement
de la science aujourd'hui c'est
compliqué d'assurer de de de de de
démontrer la la la la nocivité avérée de
des écrans en tant que tel après très
tôt dans le dans dans le développement
on sait que le le le cerveau est plus
fragile on sait que c'est ce que dis C
tison dans dans le film c'est que c'est
pas forcément digestible par un cerveau
d'enfant donc du coup tout le temps
qu'on passe devant un écran on ne le
passe pas à faire autre chose qui est
beaucoup plus enrichissant pour pour un
cerveau ensuite il y a les différentes
étapes de la vie don sur lesquelles on
reviendra peut-être au cours de de
l'émission la nocivité des écrans en
tant que tel elle est avérée selon vous
si j'ai bien compris ce que vous avez
écrit dans votre
livreobservation c'est d'abord le
terrain c'est d'abord voilà c'est les
enfants c'est leur famille c'est ce que
me disent les enfants c'est ce que me
rapportent les parents et finalement
c'est de là dont tout part hein les
études elles ne font finalement que
relater à partir de questionnaire ou
d'observation sur un temps limité moi je
suis avec les enfants et leurs famille
depuis 20 25 ans et effectivement on a
vu depuis une dizaine d'années les temps
d'exposition exposé à partir du moment
où les appareils sont devenus nomades
c'est-à-dire l'introduction des
téléphones portables des tablettes l à
ce
moment-là l'appareil est nomade le
parent perd tout contrôle sur le temps
que l'enfant y passe et le contenu et ça
ça on a des moyennes de 6 he par jour
pour les enfants actuellement qu'on peut
d'ailleurs très très bien évaluer
puisque maintenant sur le téléphone
portable vous pouvez compter et c'est
évidment ça a à partir du moment où un
enfant plus de la moitié du temps
d'éveil est passé devant un écran on
s'imagine bien il y a pas besoin d'avoir
fait beaucoup d'études en psychologie ou
en médecine ce que voulez pour savoir
que ça va impacter complètement son
développement à la fois ça un effet si
vous
voulez indirect de temps voler à
d'autres activités qui sont absolument
nécessaire pour le développement de
l'enfant mais aussi un effet direct
parce que l'écran n'est pas un objet
neutre à la fois dans le contenu mais
aussi du point de vue du contenant ça
n'a pas le même effet qu'un livre ou
qu'une discussion voilà et euh donc oui
c'est grave et pour moi c'est un enjeu
de santé publique c'est-à- direire qu'il
faut pas attendre qu'il y ait des études
qui vont mettre forcément du temps pour
agir et je je voudrais juste terminer ce
que vous venez de dire là concernant les
études le temps et cetera je pense que
cette discussion là il a paraî dans le
film que nous tout à fait tout à fait il
y a eu exactement la même pour le tabac
ou pour l'alcool c'est-à-dire que
effectivement vous êtes dans un enjeu de
santé publique on peut pas faire de
causalité directe dans ces domaines là
on peut pas dire bah voilà fumer donne
le cancer du poumon c'est pas vrai on
peut simplement supposer il faut des
études convergentes et d'un point de vue
éthique on ne peut pas faire c'est ce
que d'ailleurs dit très montre très bien
le le le documentaire on ne peut pas
faire d'études randomisé sur des enfants
avec une population de 1 an qu' on va
exposer 6 heur par jour et l'autre qui
sera pas exposé donc on est obligé de
s'en référer à des études longitudinales
et normalement le bon sens devrait faire
qu'on applique un principe de précaution
qui est que on légifère ce qui est pas
fait actuellement avant de vous donner
la parole Serge Tiron une autre question
est-ce que vous distingz tout de même la
nocivité des écrans en fonction des
tranches d'âge hein il y a apparemment
un consensus qui alors qui semble
émerger donc avant 3 ans pas d'écran du
tout hein c'est ce qui est vraiment
préconisé ça semble d'ailleurs un
consensus qui fait fois à l'échelle
internationale vous êtes d'accord avec
ça ou est-ce que qu'il faut ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que le le le le
cerveau se développe dans un continuum
jusqu'à 25 ans donc il y a pas quelque
chose qui se passe à 3 ans Bing poum
çave on peut le mettre
voilà mais les capacité d'autorégulation
de capacité de l'enfant à se réguler
elle s'acquiert progressivement en
fonction aussi des de ce qu'il reçoit de
l'environnement et donc on peut dire
pour moi par exemple à partir de 6 7 ans
il y a déjà plus une possibilité il faut
éviter avant 3 ans mais il y a pas mort
d'homme si évidemment il regarde un
écran avant 3 ans c'est pas ça qui qui
qui est grave ce qui est important aussi
et le le documentaire le dit très bien
c'est l'inférence de le fait que le
parent regarde ou pas est occupé ou pas
par son portable quand il s'occupe de
l'enfant et ça ça a des effets aussi
dramatiques que l'exposition directe de
l'enfant un alors vous souhaitez
rajouter quelque chose et ensuite c'est
promis je vous donne la parole hein
pardon c'était juste avant 3 ans en fait
c'est surtout qu'un enfant n'a rien à
gagner à passer du temps devant un écran
après on peut commencer à discuter de
boule gras en fonction du contenu des
écrans mais alors avant clairement un
gamin n'a rien à gagner et donc tout à
perdre en terme de de temps de
disponibilité d'activité plus
enrichissante pour le pour le cerveau
tout à fait bon j'ai lu une interview
que vous avez accordé au au quotidien Le
Monde il y a assez peu de temps hein
d'ailleurs euh suite à à une proposition
de loi à l'Assemblée nationale relative
à la prévention de l'exposition
excessive des enfants aux écrans hein
nous sommes donc en en plein cœur du
sujet c'est une proposition qui de loi
qui a été soumise par deux députés issus
de de la majorité euh actuel hein
Renaissance euh et vous voilà ce que
vous disiez dans dans cette interview au
Monde tous les experts s'accordde
aujourd'hui sur un point si le temps
passé sur les écrans est le moins
mauvais critère possible d'un un usage
problématique c'est en même temps un
très mauvais critère autrement dit il
est essentiel de prendre en compte à
chaque fois la possibilité d'un
accompagnement le caractère interactif
ou non interactif du support et les
contenus plus ou moins adaptés à l'âge
de l'utilisateur autrement
dit en quelque sorte vous relativisez un
tout petit peu ce qui vient d'être dit
sur ce plateau concernant l'usage des
écrans et ben non désolé de vous
contredire je vousi cité
pourant fait tout à fait mais euh cette
cette proposition de loi euh concerne
pas seulement les 0 3 ans elle concerne
les 0 12 13 voilà 0 6 ans et donc du
coup il faut bien dis pourz alors je
vais préciser ma question au-delà de 3
ans vous nuancez ce qui a été dit sur ce
plateau néanmoins alors partiellement
avant 3 ans il y a consensus d'ailleurs
il y a pas eu vraiment de divergence là
ou entre aès 3S alors alors déjà je vis
dire qu'avant 3 ans euh le consensus
enfin disons le la nécessité de limiter
le temps d'écran elle date pas de ces
dernières années en 2006in j'ai lancé le
slogan pas d'écran avant 3 ans beaucoup
de gens ont suivi et et je m'en réjouis
mais à partir de 3 ans les choses vont
se compliquer alors pourquoi ben parce
que tout simplement l'enfant va pouvoir
accéder à la possibilité de raconter les
écrans qu'il voit vous laissez un enfant
de 1 an devant un épisode de dessin
animé pendant une demi-heure c'est du
temps perdu absolu V c'est un enfant de
3 ans et demi une demi-heure devant un
dessin animé pour enfants il en manque
pas même parfois des très bons et bien
après vous pouvez discuter avec lui de
ce qu'il a vu c'est-à-dire qu'on peut
introduire des correctifs au fait que
pendant le temps d'écran l'enfant
n'interagit pas effectivement avec un
adulte mais sa quand même beaucoup de
parents et beaucoup de beaucoup de mère
de de parents isolés de mères
célibataires ont besoin d'avoir un un
temps pour eux ses parents et mettre un
enfant devant un écran c'est parfois
souvent la seule possibilité qu'ils ont
quand ils sont t seuls avec avec un
jeune enfant et mais en revanche il faut
rattraper ce temps en ayant des échanges
c'est pour ça que l'association 36 9 12
on a toujours mis en avant l'importance
de parler avec les enfants de ce qu'ils
voient et font avec les écrans et c'est
pas du tout une forme de contrôle hein
de vérifier ce que l'enfant a vu s'il a
compris c'est une manière de l'inviter à
raconter faire ce qu'on appelle la
construction narrative vous savez dans
les études PISA les Français ces enfants
français sont très mauvais ils sont
mauvais dans beaucoup de choses mais il
y a un domaine je pense où il faut
vraiment réfléchir à la place des écrans
positivement c'est la compétence
narrative si vous demandez à un enfant
de raconter ce qu'il fait à la crèche ou
à l'école maternel il va jamais vous en
parler les parents ne parlent pas de
leur travail l'enfant ne parle pas de ce
qu'il fait à l'école ou à la crèche en
revanche les dessins animés sont
tellement riche en émotion pour l'enfant
que l'enfant a envie d'en parler et si
il trouve un interlocuteur adulte pour
écouter ce qu'il dit pour choisir des
programmes avec lui pour échanger avec
lui il développe ses compétences
narratives donc si vous voulez pour moi
ce qui est important c'est pas de savoir
si les le surplus d'écran c'est la trop
grosse consommation d'écran a des effets
problématiques tout le monde d'accord
est là-dessus le problème c'est de
savoir où placer le curseur éducatif
c'est-à-dire quel discours tenir en
public est-ce qu'on va dire les écrans
sont mauvais arrêtez les écrans ou
est-ce qu'on va dire vos enfants ont des
possibilités formidables jouez avec eux
à des jeux de société discuter avec eux
de ce qu'ils ont compris et vous verrez
que finalement ils vont vous étonner et
vous aurez du plaisir à ces échanges
avec eux c'est toute la différence qu'il
y a entre des gens qui dénoncent les
écrans avec une supposée toxicité qui
n'est absolument pas démontrée et
l'association 36 9 12 qui plaide pour
une éducation à tout âge de la vie des
enfants et des parents ben de manière à
ce que les écrans ne soit plus seulement
ce qu'on regarde mais que ce soit ce
dont on discute alors j'imagine que ça
ça va vous faire réagir alors du point
de vue de de la prévention je pense
qu'il faut les deux c'est évident qu'il
faut à la fois euh comment dire
expliquer et en même temps il faut il
faut protéger c'est-à-dire
que là vous dites au fond il faut pas
dire aux parents de que les écrans sont
mauvais il faut juste leur expliquer de
jouer avec leurs enfants mais attendez
pas d'écran 3 ans c'est quand même là
vous venez dire vous venez dire il faut
pas dire il faut pas dire non il faut
juste leur expliquer qu'il faut qu'il
faut jouer qu'il faut interagir mais ça
les parents ne cessent de le faire le
problème c'est que l'écran est
extrêmement captivant pour l'enfant et
pour l'adulte et il y a un effet
d'addiction donc c'est très difficile
pour le parent de limiter le temps que
l'enfant il passe et de se limiter
évidemment lui-même c'est pour ça que
moi j'insiste sur le fait que il faut
aussi il va falloir prendre des règles
et les parents ne pourront pas seuls
pour protéger les les enfants parce que
les 369 12 ils existent depuis des
plombes mais ça n'a rien changé ça n'a
strictement rien changé sur les
pratiques les parents le savent ça les
parents savent très bien que c'est pas
bon maintenant ça va assez suffisamment
de bonnes émissions et pourtant et bien
les enfants ils sont complètement accros
alors bien sûr vous l'avez souligné
c'est parce que aussi ça ça ça ça ça
permet de de d'occuper l'enfant mais ça
le capte beaucoup plus facilement et et
bêtement malheureusement que que le
livre Raphael Itier bah sur le sur le
côté captivant justement des des écrans
il y a là encore une étude qui est
sortie cette année qui qui montrait que
sur les les les les programmes ou les
applications des tiné aux enfants il y
en a très très peu qui ne sont pas
accompagnés de publicité et
effectivement tous les ressorts de la
captologie un petit peu pour garder
l'attention des enfants et je crois que
dans le dans la loi dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure il est question d'essayer
de
réglementer le ce que l'on met dans dans
dans le dans le contenu d'un d'un
destiné à un enfant alors je ne sais pas
quel est le niveau d'efficacité de de de
de d'une éventuelle réglementation comme
ça mais peut-être que ça ça peut faire
sens dans pour un produit adressés à des
à des enfants oui il y a un très
nombreux projet de régulation européenne
heureusement il faut pas minimiser le
pouvoir des algorithmes mais vous savez
il faut pas non plus attendre de la
France de l'Europe et encore moins de la
France qu'on ait la capacité d'imposer
aux plateformes américaines de contrôler
leurs algorithmes ou de rendre leurs
algorithmes transparents c'est pour ça
que ce qui est le plus important c'est
d'expliquer alors là comme on a quitté
un petit peu les 06 ans c'est important
c'est d'expliquer le pouvoir des
algorithmes et à commencé par le pouvoir
des algorithmes dans les jeux vidéos
parce que les jeux vidéos sont truffés
aujourd'hui d'algorithme qui invite les
enfants et les adultes à rester plus
longtemps à acheter plus de produits
réels ou virtuels et à donner plus de
données enfin à abandonner plus de
données personnelles à la plateforme
mais ce que je voudrais dire à sinifo
c'est que je suis très content qu'elle
envisage l'éducation parce que quand on
lit la méthode des quatre pas pas ceci
pas cela pas pas pas ça et pas ça quand
on lit l'ouvrage on voit pas l'ouvrage
on voit pas où est la composante
éducative donc nous à 369 12 on plutôt
que de dire pas d'écran avant 3 ans on
dit maintenant jouez parler arrêtez la
télé vous savez il y a beaucoup d'études
qui montrent que les conseils négatifs
ne sont pas suivis et que il est très
important de développer une pédagogie du
positif et parce que aujourd'hui les
gens sonent extrêmement culpabilisé
facilement autour des écrans c'est
toujours plus de culpabilité toujours
plus de sentiment de ne pas pouvoir s'en
sortir et toujours plus de désespoir à
ne pas savoir comment faire alors je
voudrais quand même raconter comment est
née cette méthode des quatre pas il y a
pas de de de souci de faire campagne ou
quoi que ce soit je travaille et j'ai
toujours travaillé dans la fonction
publique hospitalière auprès des enfants
des famille pendant de très longues
années dans le 93 et et je vu donc des
familles de plus en plus englouti dans
un bain d'écran énorme et et avec des
conséquences dramatiques notamment pour
les plus jeunes et je me suis posée il y
a à peu près 15 ans la question de au
fond qu'est-ce qu'il existe dans la
littérature à ce ce sujet-là et il y
avait absolument rien en France la
littérature scientifique d'études
internationales ce qui existait c'était
uniquement des études américaine et elle
reste d'ailleurs majoritaire d'illeurs
c'est ce qui ressort aussi de votre film
hein vous avez été assez souvent aux
États-Unis pour aller chercher des
réponses à vos questions hein oui mais
enfin la science se fait beaucoup aux
États-Unis du fait de la taille du pays
et de leur histoire a moin et de mode de
financement et de mode de financement ce
qu'il existe depuis 2020 c'est les
recommandations de l'Académie américaine
de pédiatrie qui est un un consensus
très très important de pédiatre qui
donnait des recommandations très claires
il y en avait environ une vingtaine et
moi c'est quatre pas je me suis dit je
vais prendre les plus euh significatifes
dans la journée d'un enfant et faire des
recommandations qui soient à l'échelle
de la famille parce que la grande
faiblesse des 3 6 9 12 c'est de dire pas
par exemple d'écran jusqu'à 3 ans pas
jusqu'à 6 ans de consol pas de 9 ans
mais pour un pour un parent qui a un
enfant de 3 ans de 6 ans de 9 ans et 12
ans il peut absol absolument pas passer
sa journée avec un timer ou à regarder
ce que fait l'enfant il faut juste des
règles qui concernent la l'ensemble de
la journée simple et d'ailleurs ces
quatre pas maintenant sont repris sur
tous les sites c'est-à-dire des règles
simples pas le matin parce que c'est là
que laattention de l'enfant est la plus
forte pas pendant les repas parce que
c'est là où les échanges se font le plus
facilement pas dans la chambre de
l'enfant parce qu'à ce moment-là le
parent perd tout contrôle sur le temps
et le contenu et pas juste avant de se
coucher une heure à cause des effets de
la lumière bleue c'est extrêmement
simple si vous regardez les balises 369
12 vous verrez que tout ça est dedans
mais qu'il y a en même temps tout un
discours extrêmement positif qui
valorise les initiatives des parents les
échanges alors vraiment j'engage ceux
qui nous regardent aujourd'hui à lire
l'un et l'autre de vos ouvrages hein
pour pour aller au-delà et et bien
comprendre he ce qui ce qui peut vous
peut-être vous opposer he ou nuancer he
votre approche majoritairement
convergent dans majoritairement converme
Rapa i la responsabilité des des parents
euh vous responsabilisez un les parents
un petit peu hein dans votre
approcheateur elleaaraî pas beaucoup
dans ce documentaire on voit des
familles américaines
néanmoins essayer de trouver la bonne
formule pour un un déjeuner en famille
et puis finalement on voit que ces
enfants ils mangent devant un dessin
animé chacun de leur côté il y a plus
ces réunions familiales que constituent
finalement un simple
déjeuner la responsabilité des des
parents dans dans cette affaire
euh comment est-ce qu'on peut on peut
approcher ce ce ben au niveau de
l'interférence c'està dire que je
peut-être que un élément important c'est
surtout l'utilisation par les parents
des écrans parce que ils ont quand même
une dimension prescriptive sur sur les
enfant du FL tout à l'heure bibron
aujourd'hui tout en regardant son alors
c'est pas que c'est pas que prescriptif
le problème là c'est que c'est
interférent avec une avec une relation
et c'est l'objet de d'une étude suédoise
justement qui est longitudinale dont
j'ai vérifié qu'elle n'avait pas encore
abouti depuis qu'on qu'on a tourné ce
film mais donc du coup il il ils
évaluent l'environnement numérique de
l'enfant mais aussi avec les parents
pour savoir quels sont les éléments qui
sont perturbateurs et qui pourraient
aboutir à des problèmes d'acquisition de
langage c'est le principalement
là-dessus qu'il qu'il qu'il travail donc
cette étude là ils ont pris des enfants
en en très basâge et ils vont les suivre
comme ça et donc du coup cette étude est
susceptible de répondre à la question
que vous posiez quel est le le le le le
le le la la part ou le rôle parental en
dehors du côté prescriptif encore une FO
qui mais dans l'interférence avec dans
dans l'interaction avec l'enfant dont on
sait pertinemment que c'est crucial dans
dans dans le développement de d'un
enfant le psychiatre que vous êtes la
psychologue que vous êtes vous devez
faire face à des parents qui qui
cherchent des réponses aussi face à ces
questions c'est c'est le motif numéro 1
des conflits dans les familles
aujourd'hui parce que c'est éminemment
addictif pour les enfants comme pour les
adultes et donc on parlait de la
prévention qui dit pas mais moi beaucoup
de parents à qui j'ai expliqu simplement
les effets pas en leur disant vous
faites mal mais dire voilà ce que ça
fait un écran à un cerveau d'un bébé mon
comprennent je dis avec des mot simple
et me disent toujours mais pourquoi on
nous l'a pas dit avant voilà et
évidemment quand je prescris je vais
prescrire des des des limitations
c'est-à-dire qu'il a des moments qui
soient sacralisés en quelque sorte ou
des espaces et toujours accompagnés de
d'interaction avec le parents
c'est-à-dire on va faire des sorties des
jeux de société et
cetera alors il y a quand même une étude
médiamétque hein il y a aussi des études
sur le sujet qui disent que 95 % des
familles dans 95 % des familles des
foyer français aujourd'hui c'est un
sujet de discussion hein cette
utilisation des écrans le temps
d'utilisation les contenus
euh bien ce soit un sujet de discussion
c'est une excellente chose ça na pas
toujours été vous savez quand j'ai écrit
mon premier livre sur les dangers de la
télévision en 1996 qui était d'ailleurs
sous-titré les quatre risques de la
télévision et les moyens d'y remédier ça
nintéress ces personnes donc moi je me
réjouis que ce soit un sujet de
discussion après le grand problè sujet
de conflit aussi sujet mais après après
le là on parle peut-être sans doute
l'adolescence un âge j'allais le dire
j'allais le dire après le grand problème
c'est que la discussion devient un
conflit parce que souvent les parents
sont ignorants des pratique numérique de
leurs enfants donc il y a aussi tout un
travail éducatif à faire pour expliquer
aux parents que il faut qu'ils
s'intéressent au pratique numérique de
leurs enfants s's veulent pouvoir les
réguler de la bonne manière vous savez
j'avais tenté une expérience avec BG il
y a quelques années lorsque les parents
allaient acheter le premier smartphone
de leur enfant ils bénéficiaient d'une
aide aussi prolongée qu'il le voulaient
pour formater enfin pour pré pour enfin
pour organiser le téléphone mobile deur
enfant pour contrôler les différents
accès de leur enfant et quand le vendeur
disait mais comment voulez-vous Monsieur
Madame que je paramètre le téléphone de
votre enfant les parents ne le savaient
pas c'est-à-dire qu'en fait des parents
disent on ne sait pas programmer le
téléphone de notre enfant pour l'miter
et en fait non la vérité c'est c'est
qu'ils ne savent pas ils connaissent pas
les réseaux sociaux ils connaissent pas
les jeux vidéos ils savent pas comment
programmer pour comment limiter les
consommations et donc ça c'est un vrai
problème il y a toute une information à
faire pour que ces échanges qui est
actuellement entre parents et enfants ne
tournent pas au conflit c'est pour ça
que si vous voulez ce qui est important
c'est que les parents aient une
meilleure compréhension des activités
des enfants aussi parce que il faut que
les enfants puissent avoir confiance
dans ce que dans les injonctions que
leur donnent leurs parents je dois
encore ajouter quelque chose il faut
quand même pas oublier que pour beaucoup
de parents qui veulent occuper leurs
enfants autrement qu'avec les écrans il
manqueent d'alternative vous savez les
parents riches peuvent payer des tas
d'activités à leurs enfants les parents
pauvres 9 millions et demi de pauvres en
France ne le peuvent pas et pas
seulement eux d'ailleurs ce qui veut
dire que beaucoup d'enfants V pe se
demander comment faisait-on avant alors
comment faisaiton avant parce qu'es sont
pour deux raisons je peux vous le dire
elles sont bien connues par les
sociolog sont connu elles sont bien
connu par les sociologues premièrement
il y avait souvent des grands-parents
pas loin aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas
parce que les gens sont obligés de se
déplacer partout pour suiv
ou et la deè Rais les vill on été tot
btonné depuis 20 ans etcoup d'espac de
je collectif qui ex n'existe plus
ajouter à cela que les écoles restent
obstinément fermées le samedi et le
dimanche alors qu'elles pourrai
constituer des terrains de jeu
formidables donc si vous voulez il y a
les parents mais les parents n'oublions
pas son pas seulement les éducateurs
enfants ils sont aussi des gens qui
votent et qui doivent voter pour des
politiques qui ont un souci de la
politique de la ville et la politique
nationale alors quelques chiffres tout
de même 80% des 12
sont aujourd'hui équipé d'un d'un
smartphone et alors l'intrusion du
smartphone arrive de plus en plus vite
he dans la vie de d'un jeune c'est
environ 9 ans avant c'était l'entrée au
collège cé un peu le marqueur c'était
l'entrée au lycée ensuite l'entrée au
collège maintenant c'est l'entrée en CM1
CM2 semble-t-il he le premier smartphone
autrement dit la vague continue
s'accentue euh alors si vous vouiss bon
je j'acquèce là tout ce qui ce qui ce
qui a été dit chez les adolescents le
spectre numérique et se complexifie
véritablement on l'a vu dans
ce ça bouge très vite mais mais
c'estdire que on on me pas monsieur
tisron a tout à fait raison de dire les
parents doivent s'intéresser à ce qui à
ce que les enfants regardent à ce qu'ils
font mais ça va tellement vite que de
toute façon on peut pas suivre ce qui ce
qui est certain c'est qu'il faut
idéalement il faut maintenir un bon
dialogue en général avec ses enfants qui
va faire que le jour où il tombe sur une
image sur une appli qui est dérangeante
le premier réflex soit d'en parler aux
parents voilà ça ça c'est évident mais
euh euh malheureusement ça ne suffit pas
euh toujours voilà et euh euh et alors
il il y a deux aspects effectivement ces
enfants sont de plus en plus passent un
temps énorme moi voilà je vous un
exemple hier une jeune 13 ans montre-moi
parce que maintenant je travaille comme
ça on regarde avec le le portable on en
discutes qu'est-ce que tu regardes et
cetera montre-moi le temps que tu passes
moi aussi d'ailleurs je sors le mien on
compare bon voilà ah euh tiens alors
hier 9h47 ce weekend samedi 16h voilà
sur le portable hein puis après ça il y
a un détail qui nous permet de voir le
temps passer sur bon
et donc monsieur tisron a raison c'est
vrai que dans les dans les villes dans
les villes bétonnées dans le moi je
travaille dans le 93 et bien les parents
s'imaginent parfois raison que l'enfant
est plus en sécurité derrière un écran
que dehors parce que dehors bah il y a
peu d'espace vert et quand il y en a et
ben c'est occupé parfois par les dealers
et cetera je je je sais je l'ai vécu
mais n'empêche que ces objets là sont
éminemment addictifs et que moi le
problème est partout pareil j'ai été là
pendant la tout ça en Corse du Sud un
panorama magnifique et ben ils me font
venir pour parler du problème des écrans
des ados alors que la plage est là
magnifique donc voyz il y a pas que ça
quoi oui alors ces enjin pour reprendre
votre expression ils ont aussi un rôle
social parce que j'ai regardé là
concernant les applications notamment
hein ce qui fait un malheur he ce qui
marche très fort du côté des ados euh ce
sont les groupes
d'échange donc on a alors snapchat
WhatsApp et mais aussi Instagram en
réalité c'est de de pouvoir communiquer
dans des communautés créer des
communautés où il où il voilà où o va
pouvoir prendre forme leur vie sociale
alors c'est une vie sociale virtuelle
est-ce que c'est ça le problème c'est
une vie sociale virtuelle parce que
semble-t-il que ça contribue beaucoup
aujourd'hui à ce qu'on appelle la vie
sociale des jeunes en 2023ê
Rapha je voudrais votre avis sur ce
sujet là alors un avis plutôt je peux je
peux référencer ça à des études c'està
dire qu'à un moment donné on on s'est
posé la question de savoir si
effectivement l'usage des réseaux
sociaux était avait un impact négatif
sur l'humeur sur le le le le la
dépression par exemple bah ce qui
ressort avec les les bémoles he parce
qu'encore c'est c'est toujours un peu
compliqué à investiguer c'est que
l'usage des réseaux sociaux est plutôt
associé à un mieux-être oui que à un
moins moins bien-être limite de temps
défini parce qu'à partir de 2 il y a un
volume mine rapport de l'Unicef qui date
de fin décembre 2017 qui conclut que
dans le monde mais pas seulement c'est
pas seulement parce que c'est des
moyennes qui associent l'Afrique
l'Afghanistan et cetera mais parce qu'il
y a une étude très précise sur
l'Angleterre qui montre la même chose
c'est que l'utilisation que les ados
font de leur smartphon est une
utilisation qualifiée par le rapport
d'Unicef de Boucle d'or c'est-à-dire que
comme la petite fille qui a des cheveux
blonds vous savez qui trouve trois
assiettes petit moyen grand trois
chaises petit moyen grand trois lits
petit moyen grand et qui choisit chaque
fois l'assiette le la chaise et le lit
qui correspondent à ses besoins et donc
ce rapport d'Unicef conclut que les
jeunes font un très bon enfin plus
statistiquement statistiquement parce
que nous les cas qu'on voit moi j'ai
travaillé 30 ans à le dans le 94 en
dispensaire public et bien on voit
évidemment les gens qui vont mal on voit
pas les gens qui vont bien mais le
rapport d'Unicef dit que statistiquement
et bien les jeunes font plutôt un bon
usage leurs outils numériques
c'est-à-dire un usage pour renforcer les
amitiés existantes pour garder des liens
pour approfondir le le leurs
connaissances n'oublions pas non plus
que dans tout le temps que des ados pass
sur leur smartphone il y a aussi un
temps d'échange avec leurs camarades
pour pour travailler le pour pour mieux
réussir leur travaux scolaires c'estàd
qu'on peut créer une communauté pour
tout type d'activit exactement beaucoup
d'entre eux passent 3 4 heures moi je le
vois encore dans des activités de
consultation il y en a beaucoup qui
passent 3 4 heures par jour à
correspondre avec des copains pour
arriver à savoir comment traiter les
devoirs scolaires donc si vous voulez ça
c'est pas du temps non plus qu'il faut
comptabiliser comme de l'addiction aux
écrans c'est du temps de socialisation
et de préparation de leur avenir alors
première chose c'est qu'on va pas
débattre ici des études il faut aller
les regarder il y a un dernier rapport
d'amnestie internationale qui dit le
contraire il y a l'étude ban qui dit que
effectivement dans si on se limite à pas
plus de 2 he une et c'est moins de 2 he
je pense que c'est même moins d'une
heure ça a un effet plutôt positif sur
les relations sociales puisque
aujourd'hui évidemment un jeune s'il
veut se sociabiliter il a pas de
téléphone portable c'est un problème ça
on est tous d'accord ok est on est
d'accord mais après ça la la le la vraie
question c'est que un adolescent il doit
construire sa sociabilité ses
compétences sociales elles se
construisent en dehors de la famille en
relation avec ses pères mais elles ne se
peuvent se faire de manière positive
qu'avec un adulte qui les médiatise et
lorsqu'il est balancé sur un réseau
social il a accès à des millions et des
milliers de personnes sans un médiateur
si c'est comme si vous mettiez un gamin
de de un groupe de gamin des centaines
de gamins sur un terrain de foot en
disant voilà les règles du foot et puis
il y a pas d'arbitre et il y a pas de
goal il a voilà et débrouillez-vous bah
c'est la baston et ben c'est la même
chose c'est-à-dire que sur les réseaux
sociaux euh très vite ça peut dégénérer
dans du harcèlement dans des choses
comme ça parce que cette sociabilité ils
doivent la construire et ils l'ont pas
encore construite et la deuxième chose
aussi je je voudrais dire c'est que là
aussi il y a des études et vous êtes pas
sans ignorer que il y a eu une
commission d'enquête sur TikTok alors
TikTok c'est à la fois un réseaux
sociaux et un réseau social de short
vidéo et on s'est aperçu que quand on
est une jeune fille qui a 12 ans qui
s'interroge sur des problèmes de santé
mental mais tout un jeune est fragile
par nature et bien il a 12 fois plus de
chance de se voir proposer un contenu
euh lu lui lui proposant de de la
scarification des autoagressions que un
autre voyez c'est-à-dire que il y a
aussi des algorithmes qui favorisent un
usage néfaste donc il faut pas bien sûr
que c'est le moyen aujourd'hui de
rentrer en relation mais il il y a pas
que les populations fragiles il y un
adolescent par par nature est un sujet
fragile on rejo la question alternance
une alternance entre des des rencontres
dans la vie concrète et des rencontres
dans le virtuel encore faut-il qu'il a
des espaces pour des rencontres dans la
vie concrète bon ben cette fois ça sera
le le le mot de la fin je rappelle
simplement ce que rappelle la loi he
concernant ces fameux réseaux sociaux
avant 13 ans interdiction pour les
mineurs de s'inscrire sur le moindre
réseau social hein c'est ce que dit la
loi entre 13 ans et 15 ans hein il faut
l'autorisation parentale pour s'inscrire
sur un réseau social et au-delà de 15
ans et bien c'est ce qu'on peut appeler
la majorité numérique hein voilà hein il
y a toute liberté à s'inscrire sur un
réseau social lorsqu'on a plus de 15 ans
aujourd'hui en France un grand merci à
tous les trois d'avoir participé à à
cette émission Raphael tien tout
spécialement à vous après cette enquête
hein euh qui a alimenté cette émission
desbadoc aujourd'hui vos réactions ça
sera sur hashtag desbadoc sur les
réseaux sociaux justement hein et à mon
avis elles vont pas manquer les action
après cette cette émission merci à
selmaali Sarah edoline qui m'ont aidé à
préparer cette émission moi je vous
donne rendez-vous pour un prochain débat
doc ça sera la même place à la même
heure et toujours avec son documentaire
et son débat à
[Musique]
bientôt